you
mic check mic check what is going on
what is going on
the realm what's going on
dizzy what's going on lunken scrub nurse
i see you paul and p what's going on
checking the levels checking levels make
sure it's good looks like i am up first
as usual
waiting for us we're going to add a girl
here so he's up what's going on
regulator what's going on brother how
you doing man
chillin chillin getting everybody ready
spoke to
um background music sound weird yeah
too low or just like i don't know talk
to me dizzy
or just like distorted or something j
ready
five thousand son your card what's up
chili chillin ruth wait what's going on
yeah oh it's gonna be some back and
forth you already know
you already know get the coffee ready
oh thank you regulator here jesus said
the music sounded weird this one make
sure that music
background music don't sound off or
something i know i got a little lower
maybe than usual
oh man lord gotta wake up
it's like it's being played out of a can
so everyone in the jail said
okay all right i'll i'll take it with
i'll speak to grab the gun and make sure
something's going on with it
but we got some new stuff planned and
yeah there's i got some stuff for on
lock net playing too
eventually we're not going to do the
fake thing forte
oh you vacationing that's what's up man
i dread our people home the geeky nerd
dominoes really out here saving us from
um
yo with the geeky derby violin
oh yeah i got to see at him i could only
see attic with a cameo
you know where like somebody get that
new cut like they act brand new like he
brand
new right now
what's up addict i'm future mike
speaking to the people man look at the
people
yo he's fresh to death right now can you
hear me yeah we can hear you
ooh
you might get him yeah i rearranged the
how my
set uh how my setup is so my green
screen is perfectly behind me now yeah
yeah
what's going on say what's up to the
people meds what's going on
chillin bx of the fam in the building
what's going on
yeah let me know if y'all heard oh
uptown baby for the cram baby you
already know racer you already know
yo attic about to drop the hottest
mixtape so i'm telling you when you see
watch with the camera go off so you see
what's about to happen
slow what's going on silly chilly cat
daddy hustling yo hustle motivate what's
going on baby
graphic guy thank you brother for all
your help
this week it's been appreciated so he's
gonna chill out you know the king gonna
be rolling up in here any minute soon
breaking all ndas and everything you're
gonna say dear rodriguez what's going on
bro you should have been in that halo
tournament with us yesterday man it was
a lot of fun
you really do need to mute you're gonna
be here any second uh yeah he gonna be
here so we're gonna mute you know the
king gonna come in
and we will see y'all in a minute
so
nyt music thank you brother four hour
super chat i see the emoji
we're gonna be starting souls you know
waiting for all what you call to come
through king will be in here every
minute and um
but klaus should be pulling up any
minute so much love much love nyt music
so
um
uh
when you get the eye gouge what's going
on here like
hey what happened
no adjustments to like you would think
after the last night
we live now we
and we are live welcome to the iron laws
podcast and the lords of gaming.net
episode number 171 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's date
i'm very excited about our special guest
wow smitty smith oh wow smitty smith
we're gonna debut it for you baby
he said time salute to the battles in
the chat
the book of acts i don't put the time
out there for you brother put the time
out there
and i gotta hit you with the book of
acts man that's what's up that was on
time right there i respect it i respect
it
so look man very excited about our
special guest and we've got 343
delaying halo infinite more playstation
5 exclusives on deck
and epic games suing both apple and
google to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord who is not only a
friend and supporter of the realm but
with his calm demeanor
and level-headed approach to gaming news
always makes factual information a
priority
regardless of platform preference
introducing
the created host of the big cloud gaming
youtube channel and a host of the rgt
podcast our fellow ufc marvel
and playstation brethren but will always
be the professional
in our hearts live from
ga and making his long awaited debut
into the realm of the lords my man
lord big cloud gaming how you doing sir
what's going on man
man this is a long time coming that's
for sure i watch every uh every chance i
can get
so i appreciate the uh that invite for
sure
it's gonna be a good show man you
already know i know we talked a little
bit offline before but um
but four guys what you've been playing
man um they're playing some road company
with the guys on pc
uh they're playing that fall guys as
well and uh
i i've been slacking on go sushima but
i've been changing my room around like
crazy
i already know like you slacking on
ghosts of sashimi
notice he's playing everyone else's
stuff without his own
i know all the stuff that he's working
on and stuff like that
but i'm not giving you the pass brother
that she was playing that weak fallout
guys
and something else what you said what
was that pc joint that you asked me
though i don't care about how fire it is
it's not game pass
i don't hear it too much goes to the
ceiling
time
it's cool i've been playing those
chilling uh just
can't wait man can't wait for the 28th
you know what
crazy you know what's funny king
what uh he was talking about having like
uh here's a podcast for a czar podcast
kind of thing
i was like well i mean we got issues we
have different people on different
platforms
and i was like and plus king ain't
buying nothing
i'ma keep it a buck with you i don't
understand why i have a playstation i
don't understand
and then my pc is for work you see me
right here i'm working
i am working so don't ever think that
i'm gonna go
to steam and buy anything don't think
i'm going to the playstation store to
buy
anything other than those triple a
bangers that come out every three
four years oh i'm good with that moving
along
i like this conversation yeah yeah yeah
i know you do
anyway oh anyway so that's been pretty
much it it's been those those three
yeah you already know and
of course you know we have the full
hospital gaming those original lords of
the realm at the round two
wow somebody gets stitched some get this
bro give me one second we got stitch
with the two dollar super chat
uh time can't move your mic down we
can't see mario
oh you see him in the background
hold on where is he
the difficult game conqueror lord of
reviews and the how
of the new young wolf fresh cut lord
attic how we doing sir
i'm doing pretty good man i actually
woke up
early today i don't know how that
happened but you know i i'm
i'm wide awake kind of kind of i can't
say i'm wide awake
but you know let let's get this this
show on the road man let's go
you got to read he messed with the mic
and now the mario's controlling the mic
with his brain
because the mic was just that and it
just fell right back
down yo get the super chat song
yo give me all right give me one second
i no no the thing is uh
okay i thought no no i'm here i i just i
thought i had these these things that i
was talking addict about at my hands
and i i think i deleted those emails by
mistakes so
that again i have to have to log in to
find them now um okay so we got cat
daddy with the final super chat yes we
got um
iop fall guys game night put the
pressure on him
that would be put the pressure on kim
i even was like okay king what happened
wasn't the bank
for a buzzy i ain't gay pass it ain't
gay pride so so not only
is king not willing to to bite he's not
willing to have it bought for him
he's like i don't want no parts of this
throw kick in the bushes y'all he don't
want folks yeah
to keep the hair from smothering him now
you can breathe free baby
get a pedicure get your head dude
and i saw people commenting uh no the
trucker hat is not here yet
we put in a second order yeah yeah yeah
eventually adding's gonna have like five
chocolates you have five trucker hats by
the time you go
on them what else you guys are
yeah they came wiring attic only wearing
that one hat one time
so you could wear one forward one
backwards one to the other oh i ain't
wearing nothing forward nothing
backwards
sideways yeah we got
wrapped with the two dollar super chat
got my popcorn ready to hear solve rant
salute all oh today's a man i'm really
coming here just to hear someone
complain about halo that's
great that is crazy brad
i love the flip-flopper oh we all caught
up sir
yes sir we are caught and of course we
have our most technical gaming lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus mr offline
profile illuminati and lord patriarch of
the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how are you doing
sir what's good man chilling man
chilling
i have also been playing ghost with
sushima hey
bro i like listen the game is the game
is gorgeous
doesn't sound go this doesn't sound
golden but you know that there's always
a butt there's oh yeah
you got you're not saying
if i have to find one more fox then i'm
going to strangle that fox
thank you thank you
take it from someone that knows you
don't got to find any [ __ ] yeah
and and that's what i finally i i
finally upgraded all my samurai skills
so i'm beeline in the story and i'm
having much more fun okay
no no doubt so that's
just the ghost yeah yeah that's pretty
much it no doubt no doubt and of course
we have the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer the lord of combat
sports
king of the statues demands nothing less
than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert
movement beloved lord king how we doing
sir
how y'all doing this fine afternoon
listen
i hope y'all go and see uh kos dan opens
up
turn the feet around
let me see that then now let's go
yo um that statue yo it's a funny story
so when you get a chance to look at it
it's it's actually a real
i i that's when i got catfished i got
cash
switch and and and the boy boy was
highly upset but
that's what happens you know you got a
good artist out there that knows that he
can capitalize on you so he capitalized
will be said to the copyright strike
cover we keep doing that
i got to sing the whole song you know me
and donald summers got something going
on so she good though looks good
they couldn't even get us even if you
you sung the whole song
shout out to hold on apex alpha j gaming
2 super chat
just showing respect one of the better
gaming podcasts yo much love thank you
brother but yeah i thought about him
saying
better damn he can't even take the
camera baby
you gotta say you gotta say yeah bread
up
put it in color
that's what's up man thank you alpha we
really appreciate
it
what's going on king otherwise well no
i've been playing um
the solstice i i love when
brings that you know to you and um it
allows you to upgrade old armor
and you know it's you don't start all
the way at the beginning but you start
at base levels where
it's challenging and it allows you to
grow your
an armor looks incredible um they
dropped some stuff that i had to spend
some money on which one which one which
one
um the ship it was the ship
yeah i had to do it um they got my
silver and you know i only buy certain
stuff
so you know destiny because i play it
every week is what's up oh but i'm
playing under mine
um it's in game pass right now it's a
roguelike and
it's so much fun because it reminds me
of what was that game
land walker um sovereign remember land
walker from land stalkers
from genesis from genesis oh that was
the fire yeah that was a landscaper last
year
yeah it reminds me of landstalker he has
a little back bag and he looks like an
elephant yeah like yo this looks so nice
and there's
little things that you do so the fact
that it's a rogue like i'm really
addicted to these robot games
and you have really been liking a lot of
these robot games here lately
yeah i give that to sovereign
sovereignty has put me on to it but i
have this really weird question right
for for for all us gamers is it
now that we have perfected 16-bit
like fight all the developers have you
know perfected 16 bit is it next
generation that they're going to perfect
32 bit
because it's like i'm playing all these
beautiful 16
rehashes and it's actually playing and
sounding like i think they wanted them
to sound like
that back then yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna be like 84 when they start doing
3d gaming
i know right we're going to get a real
uh
uh
uh virtual fighters so that's been
yeah that's it and and you know watching
the last word um
it was a specially good episode for me i
actually loved that yeah i i think it
was
yeah that's it and the last word yeah
it will be the best when addict wears
the hat yes wow
then we got smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat i didn't got the beard
shave
now he a diva yeah yeah
just kidding there we go yeah we got cat
daddy there's a lot of adding talk today
cat daddy with the five dollar super
chat it always is what you guys talking
about
emoji yo he got a haircut he brand news
feeling sassy today yeah ada got the
pomade in his head
right now feeling himself yeah camera
all up on him
we gonna get that female demographic now
we lit
yeah it's definitely addict's world
today and of course we have the gaming
teacher himself to shinobi
little cockney you don't spread that
really
they'll
last word was lit as king said for his
personal reasons
but i definitely enjoyed it myself shout
out to uh robot
she was super lit had a good time what'd
you say excuse me um
robot cotty we call it audi for sure
yeah super super lit
you know what i'm saying it was a good
show and um yeah man where was your
guest from
um she was i don't kid you
oh i believe she's from uh she's
scottish i believe scotland
yeah what's her name again oh yo
so that's a bit more go to sheba again
like uh i'm saying
almost finished with chapter two i was
clean out the whole map act two ready
for act three
and then um yeah doing the solstice
grind like king was saying was doing
that
getting that rocking but um yeah man
soft you want to get
your chest says thirsty
to get into um some announcements sir
yes give me one second let me get this
super chat room please
um we got smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat salute to attic with
the murray's pomade
wow yeah so uh yeah
as we do every month we say thank you to
our patreon subscribers
and our youtube subscribers with the
giveaway we're a little bit late this
this week this month because we've had
some big guests and we've had the
you know we had to speed things up as my
wife looks at me dirty every time
when we pass the two and a half hour
mark i'm getting looks yeah
you guys use your automatic time emoji
so she gives you that look and then i
i'm i i e
i start eating i'm like yeah that's what
you started and that's what i know
what what was that where uh homeboy got
smacked that was on wilmy hood dreams
so let's get into these giveaways we got
first oh first of all um
lord pipio if you are in the chat see
this is the problem that we have with
our youtube subscribers
once you subscribe there really isn't
much of a way to
contact you guys there isn't a lot of
information there right so if you guys
when you win if you happen to be
listening to the show live or if you
listen to it later and you win
make sure you get at me on twitter and
and comment comment too
the comments because it is definitely
hard to contact you guys if you don't
contact me because we don't have any
information on you
all right so what we got all right so
first off we got our ten dollar gift
card giveaway
and that goes to
we got cyber knocks cyber knives okay
yeah
thank you sir you already know we have
our 20
gift card giveaway and that goes to
drop dead face man
yo shout out to hustle the motivation
chat hello everyone hello hustling
motivate you already know what's going
on
shout out to hustle word
we have uh finally our teespring
giveaway and our teespring giveaway
which you will receive sometime in the
year 2022 is
cake lent i like cake lent okay
yeah yeah yeah that's on youtube i mean
no no no on um
instagram that's okay all right congrats
to all the winners
uh once again guys thank you uh
everything you guys do on a monthly
basis supporting us
all the new people coming in every
single month it means the world to us we
would have never thought
you know nearly two years ago we would
have been here so thank you thank
everything you do thank you one last
thing too i also want to thank um all
the writers man
uh doing the new emoji for you all there
loads of gaming.net man i mean you guys
have been absolutely killing it
it's been amazing we got some amazing
pieces up right now
you know what i'm saying if you want to
get your ghost of shimon we got uh what
you call macho's got a good guide right
now about vacationing out there
you know shout out to undead we had on
last week he's been killing it
oh king he just put out article on
skyward sword man appears on amazon
just be okay with it man just chill
listen but salute the lord's gave me
that man god guys are absolutely killing
it
but um that's what i got solving
anything else well i i i got something
oh she'll get it um all right so you
know the lords we've been wanting to be
a little bit more
uh you know communicative
with the community we don't want to be a
little more commutative with the
community
so you know what what we did is uh you
know we
given a little bit more to to our fellow
members and patreons so
uh you know i went ahead and posted on
the the patreon you know i
i asked what your favorite iron lore's
podcast cast was it
and then i asked a little silly question
that if the first one got it you got
something special so
uh so let's go over a couple of the you
know
who's favorite guest some of them were
right all right so
first off first the person on uh patreon
that one was slow-mo
backslap yeah so
slow-mo one he said what is your
favorite iron lures podcast guest he
said
and then i asked what was king's first
statue ever shown uh
and so he said first statue was iron
fist and his favorite guest was jason
schreier
wow oh man listen listen i love you
slow-mo yes i love you slow-mo
did you know how far back that was
that's when one person watched my statue
that iron fist was lit you set it off
yeah i got it i got to do um i'm going
to do
because i got new camera work and stuff
like that so i'm going to revisit some
of the old stuff
no doubt no doubt um attic you want to
or solve you want to get the super chat
whatever you want yeah let me get these
questions real quick we have hustle and
motivate with the two dollars
hello everyone what's up brother no
doubt then we have hold on
i got john we got cedric h with the ten
dollar super chat sup lords finally
catching you guys
live okay all right what's up baby
so okay now let let's go to the members
uh you know
the first one was someone named viper xt
he uh you know the i obviously asked the
same question over there i said
favorite guest he said it was none other
than randolph thorpe
wow and he said the uh the original name
for the last word was
flashpoint oh he been watching it wow
yeah so definitely
if you're in that chat and uh whenever
you show up definitely put in the
comment section if you watch it after
the show
uh we'll have some type of communication
where we can get you your code
i'm gonna give you a random game for the
games that we have because we do have a
bunch of games unlocked
and we want to give back and uh be
paying attention to that chat
because saul is going to drop a random
code throughout
one random code uh anytime during the
show yeah
like right about now yeah oh man
get that get that that's the xbox code
people give it back all right
so look so what i want to do real quick
is just go over
the names that people have loved coming
on the show
we got another randolph thor we got
three rained off doors people
one of my all-time favorite episodes i'm
pretty sure he's talking about when red
came on and it was like four and a half
hours long
i don't know i mean because he would
have said red and hip-hop
i i got i i've got a lot of like
feedback that that was their favorite
guest show
he might be talking about another one
but uh you know who knows
then we got a dealer someone yeah
what's funny is jonathan b said favorite
guess is a tie between cogs mobster hat
and addicts
i still got that
we had corey hale with the 15 super chat
shout out to the realm shout out to the
chat preach lords hit that like super
chat
works no doubt absolutely
good so we can get it yeah we're we're
perfectly fine you know we're gonna do
that a little bit more often
you know i'm just gonna randomly drop
some some stuff so definitely pay
attention to the community times i'm
trying to keep this a little bit more
update
uh being a little bit more uh you know
you've been acting communicating with
them
if i see enough of you guys out here
actually participating
maybe i might cross party lines you know
you don't know
i might be on some game that you got to
buy
a game that's not all game pass sir
it doesn't make any sense i don't even
know why they got a playstation now like
what's going on oh my god
shout out to jonathan b for winning the
code uh that is
that code is for the xbox version of
lego marvel collection
you got a bunch of games in there so
hold on hold on hold on
we got my bro up in here we got the 50k
lord of the last word
my man he bounces up in the chat wow
what's going on brother good to see you
congratulations brother
much more success and i'll see you on
friday at the campfire to argue with you
and it's proof that you're wrong
no that's my guy man salute so proud of
him super proud of him man you have no
idea so now that we got into what all
the bills we got everything everybody's
playing
we gotta start with lord big cloud who
has been patient
his video game system you telling your
children
we don't have to go to trophy scores man
why don't you beat me and fall guys
let's start there
oh you want four five we can run after
this
so anyway we'd like to discuss uh little
big clowns video game system history his
journey as a content creator and of
course what led up to creating his
amazing
youtube channel recently over 7k right
it was like 7k
bro
that's good bro and of course the rgt
podcast so lord
big cloud let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
so it's crazy you know i've been gaming
since i was five nice uh my sister got
me into the whole thing
it was kind of like the babysitter in a
sense where she didn't wanna
actually do anything she had her atari i
played a few games on there
but then i ultimately i didn't own my
own system until the playstation
one okay and then um i actually went and
got the 64
and uh the sega and a few others you
know i did have this
i got that a little later we gotta slow
you down we gotta clarify
which sega sir we gotta clarify this is
very strange
oh my man that's right he was out there
i was hyped to tell when i got that we
played sonic all that
and it was crazy because you know um i
went outside a lot you know i showed but
it was like you know something
it was something about the video game
world that just drew me in more you know
it drew in my time
you know i spent more time on there um
brothers got into it
i got a question for you just just real
quick because you just glossed over
something that was truly amazing that i
just heard from you
um yeah yeah nintendo 64.
right did you get a chance to try it
before you brought it
i wanted um did you just buy it first
oh i played it on the friends because we
had the couch co-op type thing back in
the day
my friend who lived down the street he
had owned it
and um my other one who uh moved to
cincinnati
he actually had the uh playstation one
before me
you know okay we used to always go over
each other's houses it kind of felt like
carpooling and it says we would go over
to
you know that for his house you always
gotta feel bad for
the person that you always went to his
house because like he never got to play
his game
that's the display dude the display dude
is happy to do that yes
but i don't remember my display dude
being that happy but okay
yeah those game nights man game nice was
lit back in the day man it was it's
so the reason why i asked this
particular question
when you first got a chance to try that
analog
on